hasta ahora hemos trabajado con la
fuerza y las leyes de newton en
esencialmente una dimensión cosas que
van de arriba a abajo o de un lado a
otro
ahora vamos a expandirnos un poco
introduciendo vectores como lo hicimos
en los problemas de movimiento de
proyectiles en dos dimensiones para
estudiar ahora las leyes de newton en
dos dimensiones
digamos que tenemos una superficie
congelado digamos un lago un lago
congelado todo esto es agua congelada
porque porque en mi problema no quiero
trabajar con fricción eso ya lo veremos
más adelante
entonces suponiendo esto es hielo adiós
esta es una superficie parejita de hielo
y además voy a tener encima un cubo de
hielo
de nuevo para evitarnos trabajar o
involucradas la fricción en este punto
y es más vamos a imaginarnos que entre
el cubo de hielo y la superficie del
lago hay aceite para asegurarnos que no
tenemos ninguna fricción
vamos a imaginarnos que me encuentro
empujando este hielo o jalando este
hielo
entonces
voy a voy a imaginarme que este cubo de
hielo tiene un gancho
y además tiene una cuerda
y esta cuerda
va a ser salada
por una persona puede ser yo puede ser
ustedes cualquier persona
más o menos
aquí está
este es un ejemplo un poco más realista
porque bueno es más fácil si ustedes
jalan algo que lo jalen de esta manera
entonces aquí tenemos
que estamos jalando moviendo esto pero
no solo en una dirección aquí por este
ángulo de la cuerda también estamos
moviendo un poco hacia arriba
entonces
bueno
si yo estuviera empujando esto solito
hacia la derecha sin tener este ángulo
puedes resolver este problema sería muy
fácil si yo quisiera ser recuerda es la
fuerza necesaria para mover este bloque
pues explicó la fórmula de f igual a
fuerza igual a masa por la aceleración
pero lo que voy a hacer como les digo es
calcular este tipo de problema en donde
tengo un movimiento hacia la derecha y
un movimiento hacia arriba
yo estoy jalando la cuerda y digamos que
esta cuerda va a tener un ángulo con
respecto a la horizontal
va a tener un tener un ángulo de 30
grados
y digamos que este bloque de hielo es
bastante pesado este bloque va a pesar
50 kilogramos casi lo de una persona
y yo estoy jalándolo con una fuerza o
vector
y lo estoy jalando con una fuerza
diez minutos o también pueden verlo como
que esta cuerda tiene una tensión de 10
minutos más adelante veremos haremos
vídeos sobre problemas de tensión pero
bueno al menos para este programa
problema tenemos que la fuerza con la
que halo es de 10 10 minutos mi pregunta
es qué tan rápido se va a acelerar este
bloque bueno
esta pregunta tiene dos partes en qué
dirección se va a acelerar y en qué
dirección se va a acelerar
bueno pues vamos a averiguar si queremos
saber qué tan rápido se va a acelerar
hacia la derecha o en esta dirección
donde lo estoy jalando
pues bueno ya que también estoy jalando
un poco hacia arriba
sin embargo como ustedes podrán
imaginarse 10 newtons no es la
suficiente no tenemos la fuerza
suficiente para levantar este bloque de
50 kilogramos así que me lo quiero hacer
ver su velocidad hacia la derecha lo que
vamos a hacer es descomponer este vector
en sus elementos horizontales y
verticales
justo como lo hicimos con el vector de
velocidad en los vídeos pasados
lo más sencillo es visualizarlo como los
lados de un triángulo rectángulo o
quizás también como un rectángulo vamos
a
y dibujar el diferente color
bueno la magnitud horizontal si se
imagina en esto
como una unos ejes o coordenadas
cartesianas
y este es el eje x bueno la magnitud
horizontal va a ser más o menos este
valor en x
en este sentido
y esto lo vamos a llamar fuerza en equis
o la fuerza hacia la derecha del eje
horizontal
la magnitud horizontal bueno ya
definimos que es esto
si queremos saber la magnitud
vertical en
bueno podemos a partir de este mismo
punto como el ejemplo del eje cartesiano
y más o menos
calcular o encontrar el valor en el eje
y
este sería f
o también otras personas prefieren
algunas personas prefieren dibujar los
vectores todos partiendo de un mismo
punto pero a otras personas también les
gusta dibujar
este sistema descomponer estos vectores
como si fueran
elementos de un triángulo rectángulo
así entonces cualquiera de estas dos
maneras es es la misma es lo mismo
ustedes pueden usar cualquiera bueno
entonces vamos a trabajar con esta forma
de triángulo y para esto vamos a
necesitar nuestras funciones
trigonométricas
así que recorremos nuestras funciones
que son
seno
coseno y tangente
bueno sabemos que estos 10 minutos es la
longitud de este vector o la magnitud de
este vector va a ser la hipotenusa de
este triángulo y queremos averiguar el
lado adyacente adyacente a la fuerza en
x qué función trigonométricas vamos a
usar bueno en este caso vamos a usar la
función coseno que es cateto adyacente
sobre hipotenusa así que tenemos vamos a
usar otro color un poquito diferente
vamos a ver qué tal se ve este
tenemos que el coseno de 30 grados
es igual
el valor del cateto adyacente que en
este caso es f x lo que quiero
encontrar
entre la hipotenusa que en este caso es
10 si despejó este x
fx va a ser igual a 10 x
el coseno de 30 grados si ustedes saben
de memoria las relaciones de sus
triángulos de 30 60 y 90 grados se
acordarán que este coseno de 30 grados
es raíz de tres enteros
entonces
vamos a sustituir f x es igual a 10 x
raíz de 3 entre 2 10 entre 2 es igual a
a raíz de tres
newtons
y ahora podemos conocer la aceleración
en x ya que tenemos la fuerza en este
eje
entonces
vamos a usar ahora amarillo
quiero conocer la aceleración en x voy a
usar mi fórmula de fuerza en x es igual
a la masa
por la aceleración en el eje horizontal
conozco la masa de 50 kilos acabo de
encontrar mi fuerza de espejo mi
aceleración aceleración en x es igual a
la fuerza en x entre la masa que es
igual la fuerza
en x quedamos que 5 raíz de 3 newtons
y la masa que está en kilogramos estoy
trabajando bien con mis unidades es de
50 kilogramos
entonces esto me queda que es igual a
raíz de 3
entre 10
metros
por segundo al cuadrado disculpen la me
faltó el espacio aquí pero bueno
bueno qué más pasa con este bloque ya
encontramos la aceleración en x
bueno como ven estoy es jalándolo con
cierto ángulo así que va a haber un
componente hacia arriba acá eso estoy
levantando el bloque de alguna manera
bueno vamos a usar la misma lógica ahora
quiero conocer este componente
es
mi fuerza
y ahora vamos a usar mi función seno y
en este caso tenemos qué
el seno de 30 grados de la misma manera
que hicimos en el caso anterior es igual
a mi cateto opuesto que en este caso es
mi fuerza en y entre la hipotenusa que
vale 10 minutos despejó mi fuerza
es igual a 10 por el seno de 30 grados
pero el seno de 30 grados es un valor
mucho más sencillo de encontrar es igual
a un medio entonces 10 entre 2 es igual
a
5 minutos así que estoy levantando el
bloque con una fuerza de 5 minutos
piensen un poco en esto cuál va a ser la
fuerza que me va a estar jalando hacia
abajo ya que esto está en el planeta
tierra y la fuerza de gravedad me va a
estar jalando
hacia abajo bueno vamos a calcular la
fuerza de gravedad de hecho vamos a
ponerla en otro color
mi fuerza de gravedad
hacia abajo la calculó mi fuerza de
gravedad
es igual a la masa que son 50 kilogramos
por la aceleración de la gravedad que es
aproximadamente 10
metros por segundo al cuadrado entonces
50 por 10 resulta que tengo una fuerza
de 500 minutos hacia abajo que me está
jalando este bloque
quiero conocer la fuerza neta que se
aplica en el eje vertical de este bloque
mi fuerza neta
es igual a en este caso mi fuerza de
gravedad menos mi fuerza en el
componente llegue a la que estoy yo
levantando con la cuerda
y esto es igual a 500 minutos menos 5
neutros
así que se nota que por mucho la fuerza
de gravedad esto es 500 newtons hacia
abajo y 5 newtons hacia arriba nos
quedan
495 newtons hacia abajo donde pues bueno
con esto estamos viendo que no estamos
para nada levantando este bloque hacia
arriba
lo único que hacemos es disminuir un
poquito la fricción que puede haber en
este bloque
y bueno hasta aquí llegamos en este
tutorial los veo en el siguiente vídeo